the last talk of today
and he will be talking about the second
Khan kalai conjecture please go ahead
yeah
can you hear me yeah
sure So yeah thank you very much for the
invitation it's my great pleasure to be
giving this talk
uh so yeah exactly the topic will be the
secondary conjecture and this is Joint
work with elkanan Mossel from MIT
Jonathan from NYU and Nike sand from MIT
okay
so what will be the model we're going to
work on so it will be the simplest
graphone possible so this will be some
some work on the constant intervals okay
so like the previous talk everything
will be like at those Randy models so
like you know we obviously know what it
is like and vertices P could depend on N
probability of ads IID and by G bulgy I
would know the genre okay
now we will take a subgraph okay of
eight of the complete graph Indian
vertices okay so you know this will be a
crucial object right so like it is a sub
graph
K N is a complete graphene and where
this is it could be a triangle it could
be um
it could be triangle it could be like a
login click it could be a perfect
matching if n is even Hamilton and
circle whatever okay and what we care is
about the following probability so you
know this is not the suburb count for
example in previous talks this is kind
of existence of the copy so we care
about the probability that the sample
from GNP contains an isomorphic copy of
eight okay and this is a very
fundamental of course event
and right so poor be those probability
hopefully that it's clear and we care
about criticality okay so we want we
want to understand the criticality p as
a function of faith of course of n as
well so that this probability is half
and you know why do I call criticality
you know it's a very it's a very
fundamental result in this direction the
volume result that claims that actually
the point where this becomes half is
actually a phase transition point where
if if your probability is much smaller
than this big critical the probability
zero otherwise goes to one so somehow
all the action happens at the constant
times PC okay so like we want to
identify the the window you know
essentially that you know
okay so this is a very fundamental
result it's like a huge literature of
course I'm sure many of you here have
worked in one way or another in finding
this critical
PC okay sure
no eight
arbitrary it's an arbitrary thing right
for things we know everything by the way
but we'll be done with it
PC is is not zero right so like
intermediate value of 3.0 it is not the
complete graph so like you know there is
an intermediate value it could go
thank you
right and okay so cool so what's the
first approach that anybody should take
here right so like the first approach I
think what we should play is try the
first moment okay so like what the first
moment method right so you can take
attribute or the software sound like the
the copies of Fades in Z right and
equivalently what I'm asking is to study
this probability right so the
probability that like there exist at
least one
right I understand when this becomes
half there's a driven upper bound okay
so by markov's inequality this is the
most expected value of this scope is and
why you know that's a nice bound is
getting a lot of expectation if I denote
and now start with a little bit of
notation M sub base for me is the number
of copies of Fades in the complete graph
okay so like uh right for triangles M of
triangles and to string okay so by
length of excitation this is m m of 8
times the probability that the specific
copy appears which is p to the edges of
it
okay so as long as I make this this one
to be half I have a lower bound on
critical
makes sense because it's an upper bar
with the probability of error so let's
solve for this so the first moment that
is going to face the psychology p108
it's just you know this is just the four
wheeler one over two M of H to the one
over the axis which is atmospheric value
nothing funds okay that's also being the
first approach that anybody should think
about if they think about this probably
is a state
well the classic recipe is like the
second moment method which is you know
it's a control on the variance of this
thing and you know trying it right it's
uh the expected value let's write some
example you said to three p to the three
right three but this is three edges
is actually correct okay so that's
actually not the trivial bound
and really well there's actually an
upper bound as well uh we'll try the
next single example before clicked right
four six is four four six six edges one
over n to the two thirds good that's
also correct this is the correct
prediction
let's go once of level of sophistication
above right so like if we have like a K4
with an antenna
okay
so then we have like five vertices and
seven edges
[Music]
I'm really sorry
good yeah so we have like five vertices
and uh seven edges and the the P1 is
like one over into the five over seven
but something happened the per critical
is not anymore the lower bound so this
is not tight this is one over into the
two thirds and the question is what
happened okay so like you know why this
is something we completely understand
what happened is the following you know
like conceptual kind of pictures that I
want to build kind of in this
introduction that something happened in
the sub graphs here so like when we are
asking about the probability of this
graph appearing here but somehow when
this graph appears in GNP this
subgraphic actual K4 appears also and it
so happens that because this is more
dense this is harder to appear in
expectation in GNP in particular
this because this you know the K4
appears we know the threshold for the k
for appearing and when the expectations
to be scared for appearing we have a
better if you will lower bound on
criticality which comes from this here
in a very simple logical implication
that just said if a copy of Fates
appears in GNP then a copy of H Prime
appears in GNP Again by this simple
observation and doing the mark of
inequality now for H Prime you get a
better load bound which is actually
maths is the the K4 level which is
actually typed okay so there is some you
know some methods here that somehow the
subgraphs here carry information about
this this critical pressure
cool so let's actually employ the
strategy more let's define the first
moment method so the probability of NH
appearing on a comment when I mean sub
graph here I'm talking about ads in view
servers okay not not vertex into subnet
so like it's any sub collection of
phases of AIDS appearing and that's you
know that's important to do not use
anything so I think of it as a
collection of feds if you go on the
complete graphs all right so
right so this is the kn
and vertices and all the possibilities
and I think of it as collection of edges
okay
so let's let's do this this improval
thing so like the problem you didn't
quite like
here
so everything is labeled in this sense
that the complete graph is is uh
is is uh you know no but when you say a
triangle appears I could ask when does a
triangle one two three appear
right you cannot spend the time you want
the three appears but like what I'm not
so are you asking for
vanda's automotive copy of that graph
appear or do you ask exactly no I'm
saying when the probability that there
existing isomorphic copy of Faith so
right so you didn't so age because you
said H is the sub graph of k n you mean
you can imagine it is label but then I
take the uh
so you won't unlip yeah I care about the
existence of a non-label right
uh okay so uh yeah of course please stop
me if you have any questions so it's the
probability that like a copy of its
appears is that most Now by Marcus and
quality the minimum of a Rolex Prime of
this expected value which I can evaluate
by the unit of expectations this is M of
H Prime again this is the Corpus of
Fates Prime
in the complete graph the probability of
a specific its prime appearing into the
E8 okay good we have a better up and
bound before we had only its prime equal
relates and if we make the right-hand
side half
we get a refined lower bound which you
know we call it and it's called also the
subgraph expectation preschool for AIDS
which is you know just like the maximum
roll its prime operates and you see the
formula again one over two m is prime to
the one over three square and that's a
load
okay good so that's better because you
know it covers the Escape for less than
10 now
and you know this is actually correct so
to answer to this question right we know
everything this is the correct thing
about current 20 seconds we know about
much more of course and this also will
connect also for login clicks and this
is kind of start that it sort of you
know textbook second moment applications
here
and this is so correct and there are so
not major I would take another examples
and I would say I was playing what I
mean by this that actually led to what I
referred to as the second light
conjecture so Canon can lie in 2006 they
they tied you know to find an account
and tell them essentially of this and
they ended up with conjunction that this
is actually correct okay so like let me
explain
a small detail so first of all what they
mean exactly correct that there existed
Universal k
okay under which any eight eights could
depend on them and as I explained from
here this is the interesting case if it
depends on them
right Patrick Martin Hamilton and psychi
like whatever you you can think of this
is at most K times this thing so this
was a lower bound right and until it's
an upper bound up to a low guard okay so
that is like a a slack of a logarithm of
the number of Fades of the number of
edges in it
you know why there's a logarithm it's
because you know you may know the
examples of perfect match of Hometown
and cycle in these cases you know we
know that Logan Over N right because it
needs to be connected the GNP but they
actually the first the the subgraph
expressions
so it doesn't get distinct and there is
actually some other very nice Direction
because of the coupon connector to
explain this logarithm we don't we're
not there it is also an open problem but
right up to a logarithm so that's the
second kind of like conjunction
first and we come to it
conjunction
right so so I referred to a second
calculate because this contract should
do in this paper okay we'll come to this
okay cool is this clear so the setting
is the question clear right okay
now I will in the next slide so this is
open this is open like more about 15
years later it's a there is no I would
say
right possibly prior to this work there
is not like significant progress in this
direction uh
in this note in this question but there
is like major uh kind of breakthroughs
if you want in in very near in the
neighborhood of this convection okay so
let me explain a bit and possibly the
calculate conjunction so like let's do a
little bit more literature because you
know I kind of owed to given the recent
breakthroughs so like uh right so um
then one can can go in a level of
abstraction more right and actually did
in the paper and they said okay how
about we just discuss about monotone
properties okay non-trivial monotone
properties of subsets of random subsets
okay so Random subjects just means you
know the product measure of an elements
let's say and and take these random subs
and I ask does it satisfy this monotone
property whatever that is right
and the non-trivial element is the empty
set monitor I mean if you add the
element you know it's still satisfied
and not Revel I mean you know it's not
that it's like uh Satisfied by
everything or nothing okay so it's uh so
so it has a terrible behavior and right
so the empty set or like right you
understand probably what I mean by this
and the the critical threshold is
similarly defined so that the
probabilities actually half right and
your main is this yeah for p equals zero
this is not satisfied for prequeline
that's why there is such a critical
intermediate value theorem I think
and you can ask you know what is this
big critical and you know just like to
to ground things for us what I'm saying
is if you can imagine this to have some
structure like to be the edges of the
complete graph right we're back in our
setting and we're discussing about
monotone properties as a specific type
of monotone property which is the copy
of the the the web Israeli sample
containing a copy of face okay this is a
monotone property and you know this is
what I'm discussing in this talk just to
put the correspondence but this is you
know obviously a much more general
setting
and you know just that I this is again
has a threshold Behavior understand
applies in in the setting so it's a you
know this is the the window is what it
is you know okay so what would is the
canker like conjecture so like they
motivated by the subgraph thing I
explained
they they Define some notion of Calvin
okay of a property so like what's a
what's a cover of a property it's like
you know it's it's it's a cover is a
subset of sets from one to n that kind
of necessarily appear when f is
satisfied okay so like um right so like
for us before it was like a cover is you
know all the union of all the copies of
H Prime if H Prime is a subset so
whenever an H appears one element of H
Prime appears as well but you know you
can imagine much more General things
right so cover everything is
just understand it's like you know any
kind of
like finite you know collection of sets
you can think of that kind of they
necessarily appear when f is satisfied
okay
and then they associate the first moment
threshold to every cover and which are
you know trivial by similar Mark of
inequality reasoning gives also a lot
about this general setting and the
conception is actually tight so like in
this specific setting for this notion of
cover that you know there is a natural
generalization or for the Fresno Metro
escorts of course okay
Wednesday there is a quantity so there
is the same the same exactly thing yes
my ambition here there is a gate here
yes
and just again to ground things what's
happening with what I'm saying the
second can I conjecture so right so this
is more General this is a more general
setting in this sense
but there is their notion of cover
actually makes the possibly covers more
than just sub graft covers I described
for you so like at this level of
comparison within literature is what I
want to get somehow the notion of covers
right which is before what I told you
it's like if if a copy of Fates appears
a copy of H Prime appears this is a very
specific type of cover you can imagine
like much more complicated type of
covers like you know for any AIDS you
choose a different H Prime I don't know
in in your complete graph so you know
this is kind of gives a finally weaker
bound let's say but of course you know I
don't want to take any of the glory of
this conjunction because you know it's
obviously very general and yeah
yeah
okay
now literature like this happened in
2006. so telegram came with a paper in
2010 and
suggested a relaxation if you wanted a
modification of this conjecture because
you know it has been open for four years
then and to make essentially recovers
fractional coverage okay so like to take
the the covers and you know if you're
familiar with what it is a cover or I
have a graph is a fractional version of
it and again you know by a little bit
more sophisticated Mark of inequality
that gives a lower bound and he said
okay maybe it's you know we cannot find
a counter example even that you know for
the maximum of fractional covers and
let's let you know what's known as
fractional
and okay so breakthroughs nine years
later
it is the fraction language was proven
and uh by this is a greater group in
Rogers
um and you know this is great news and
the what what Saints in the mathematical
understanding we have like in these nine
years actually that has been another
proof the same year of something very
famous in combinatorics and a lot of
theoretical computer science called the
sunflower conjecture okay so the sulfur
conjecture is like a a very nice
combinatory comparative question that
that doesn't have to ask in the 60s and
it hasn't been an improvement since but
like until like uh Lovato and other
people from UCSD like they actually
found a way to to almost get to the
threshold almost and they proved like
this I considered amazing intermediate
dilemma which is called the spread Lemma
or at least I call English which is a
it's like you know it was a bit powerful
tool and these people know this and and
they use it okay so we'll come to it
and and right so and then this year we
had another break in this direction
because Park and Farm proved the actual
language okay so approved without the
relaxation using ideas from the spread
level but yeah
good so now what I want to do is I want
to revisit the the first thing right so
the the graphing so like you know which
is still missing kind of you know the
right type of covers because you know
you can say of course can I compute this
thing you know can I evaluate this thing
and of course Case by case you can
compute but you know it's it's it's not
like that it's such a simple if you call
formula like you know as the as the
second kind of like conjunction would
say about the graphs
right
okay
and uh cool so uh what we do okay so uh
okay so this is just to remind you here
what's happening so that back to our
setting right because you may have I may
have like a literature there is the
sample of excitation threshold this is
the formula coming from this very simple
Mark of inequality arguments right and
The Logical implications that's
described the fates appears it's Prime
appears you know and you can imagine it
as a subset of coverage a very
particular type of coverage and second
can I could actually you know claims
that like this side
have to look at it and of course
and okay what do we do so we modify a
little bit the threshold so the pre I
you know like I throw a formula here I
will explain so we take this particular
threshold and we're a little bit
modified it in a way I will explain so
there is this right I promise to explain
there is some some hidden thing MH Prime
commits that are include in this
optimization problem in this protected
formula
which oil also comes from first moment
reasoning that I will explain so like I
I Define this you know we Define like
this this uh this modified like a budget
problem which we prove first of all it's
sandwiched between the subjects the
traditional and the critical electrical
threshold for all names
and second is actually correct so like
up to this K and the logarithm this is
another one
so this is the the contribution so like
it's a proof of a modified version
right some comments obviously I owe you
this okay but the okay but at this level
hopefully that that makes some sense
uh cool so you know contribution I guess
it's a subgraph formula right so there's
no you know arbitrary covers it's a very
you know simple you know the simplest
coverage you can imagine up to a Twist
that I will explain and you know it's
actually I would say exactly a simple
and formula if you want like this one's
foreign
like uh you know perfect matching like
this is us through
and
um
okay another thing I kind of like it has
a very short proof so like if the the
moment you define things correctly and
especially this object like you
right you just usually essentially this
this very I would say you know kind of a
powerful Lemma and you get it so with
the launch I will explain this hoping I
will present the whole proof essentially
and um right so this again as I said
this was amazing it's a main tool and a
Major Tool in the breakthroughs of
proving the sunflower lemon
so even if you don't get about at all
but I'm saying here I think that's a
good technique to keep in mind
and I have a final thing to say right so
if most you know you know we have a nice
mix here in this workshop with
statisticians and probabilists and you
may be wondering okay but that doesn't
have some statistical application that
like you may imagine or some this kind
of thing actually it's interesting it
kind of goes the other direction so like
we proved that we found paxili and also
proof of this spread level in
combinatorics with statistics so like we
have also it right so so like you know
usually okay probability and at least I
take probability and apply to statistics
we actually found a way to argue about
this powerful tool that implies all
these direct results and our result as
well with Statistics so like I want to
go all service so somehow you can also
prove these results and also these are
results yeah I want to describe another
Direction kind of another layer in these
results okay
so that's the
that's available
uh now let's start saying what I hide
for you from you right okay so uh what
is this m of H Prime commits that you
know kind of clears this Gap it's a very
graphic it's a very clear thing but
let's make sure we understand it this is
just the object that says give me names
and give me a sub graph of AIDS like a
Nets Prime and just give me the number
of copies of its family names Okay so
um right so it's not a hard thing but
just to make sure we understand so if
it's a triangle if it isn't trying
and enabled a specific ranking okay and
then we have H to B
and an edge then I'm asking you know mam
of H Prime comma 8 is the number of
edges in this network
if it's Prime you know was like a
Prime commits
is one okay so I will stop the realities
with one trivial observation what if
like you know you have like a bunch of
surroundings okay right okay so I
stopped interval this like you know if
this is eight let's say this is a
hundred of them and eight is this and H
Prime is a dragon right okay and
obviously this thing is okay so when am
I going with this so like like hopefully
this this notion is trivialized enough
so like the the the thing now is
how do we use this so what's observation
why how do you improve this lower bounds
from The Logical implication of a copy
of faith in pleasure copy of its prime
okay remember what was like we use this
inequality right that if H appears in
GNP then H Prime appears in CNP a copy
for its final present zp but it's kind
of missing something right so if missing
what if AIDS was this like having a
hundred triangles and Nate's Prime is a
triangle then there's something missing
in the quality right the probability of
like a AIDs appears implies the
probability of a hundred triangles
appearing in the GNP okay which you know
you may think of initially come on will
this matter I mean it turns out that
actually from this perspective it does
make a difference of course we can
discuss you know about fundamentals or
not but right okay what am I saying here
let's improve the first moment threshold
okay so the probability that H appears
is that multi probabilities that like
foreign
okay it's at least right so this is also
true which in particular implies this
right
okay so please remember the market which
gives me a better bug
finally out of expectation so let's make
this half now okay so if I make this
half I get this formula I promise for
you from here right like which is the
maximum overall it's Prime of this ratio
M of H Prime commits 2 m of H Prime and
this thing which is a load by the coach
yeah because again because like the
probability and you know remember you
may don't remember okay maybe we can
don't need to write it this was one
before right so this way it's in between
okay so far so good I mean this is the
new lower ball
and the good thing this is type okay so
like let's see why this is type
um
right so what's the main result
is that if this is the formula this is
at most a constant time the logarithm oh
that's an eight sorry
okay uh
I guess a natural question here is why
there is a logarithm still right because
I explained the logarithm because of the
previous thing being one over n in the
hamiltonian cycle this is the same here
sorry I have performed by the same
things it's a big use a living condition
but it's a true computation this is one
over n and you know the truth is Logan
over there so like this is uh like this
this log should still be there so we're
not like you know full sitting or like
on sitting in any way
okay uh cool so now I want to explain
the spread Lemma and the proof of the
upper bound uh right so I have to
advertised it enough so hopefully it
will you know stay at the level I
promise for you so like uh okay so
I need the nausea
uh of spread measure okay so what's a
spread measure so um
okay so welcome to complete graph okay
and imagine you have defined a
probability measure which outputs a sub
graph of the complete graph
and right so a is the sub enough and P
is the low Pi is the low
and we say that this is our spread so
we're going to like a measure which is
spread and in which sense you know it
doesn't like accumulate in a specific
thing like Photo specific labeled if you
want subgraphs of the complete graph the
probability that it contains this
specific subject is at most you know a
specific rate R to minus the edges of s
okay so let's let's try to see if you
understand what I'm saying right so like
I say the following like if you have a
specific s right so that like for any
specific case
what's the probability that like the
random a will include this s
okay
and I want this to be small okay so I
want I don't want to put a lot of mass
in containing specific circulars okay so
that's what it's spread measure it's a
definition it's not there I'm not saying
that it's anything so far
okay nothing on gympie right this is a
property of the complete graph and a
specific measure on it
what is spread dilemma okay so the
spread dilemma says the following uh if
we have
choose your favorite M sub graphs of the
complete graph okay it could be anything
you imagine the I don't know like all
the edges or like all the triangles I
don't know anything you you want M could
grow with n like there's no restriction
just I want a parameter K that bounce
all the all the number of edges of this
Hardware okay so K is an upper bound on
the possibly a number of edges
and I want another structural property
of this collection of soundclouds I want
the uniform measure on them to be our
spread
okay so let's let's okay let's go again
so choose your favorite collection of
subgras assume that they have at most K
edges all of them
and okay so maybe let's now those are
our neighbors
these are enable subjects exactly right
they are specific sabotage of K sub n
so like these are you know your favorite
subgraphs and somehow they are kind of
spread out okay so like they they
satisfy this property they're a spread
measure the uniform measure is a spread
measure so they don't accumulate in a
certain way in a disappropriate
Quantified way
[Music]
it means exactly for this label that's
great thank you right right exactly yeah
good so in particular for GMP that's
automatically our spread where R is one
of our favorite yes yes exactly exactly
good yeah
it's under these two conditions for the
GI we can find the density of GNP
containing Center U1 of the GIS okay so
this is enough
reason for the GNP contained one of the
GI specifically for the density p with
scales like log K override okay so this
is the
right so for p equal low K Over R that's
the
that's the
density K is the number of edges if you
want to get the eyes and R is the
spreadness Wyoming there have been
simply contains one of ten probably 0.9
like you can make this
Okay let's listen it's an existence
now let's see how we apply it for
example right so what how do we get what
the result we want we want to copy of
face appearing in the NP so I have the
question
where where do I see the end appearing
depending on them no excuse me about
this yes for some unique webs and see
okay but but in your statement the uh I
mean the m is not appearing it's not
appearing in your P it's not appearing
in your knowing 0.9
exactly so L doesn't matter for this
estimate here because it's assuming the
spreadness okay yes it's independent of
fun yeah okay
okay how do we apply it okay so like now
take all the possible copies of Fades in
the complete graph okay so then as long
as you prove itself spread because K is
the number of edges of phase so it's an
easy like we just apply this level right
so take Z1 to GM to be all the possible
copies of Base
okay wait wait wait wait what what
depends on what so
can you do a I mean you don't have to
write it but can you do it for all let's
exists so is K fix does K depend on N is
season arbitrary parameters so wait but
C can also depend on NC no no that's
important sorry guys I need to have the
three lines this is universal yeah
that's the universe let's see such that
for all k for all our for all G1 up to
GM that's holds yes okay
and okay so okay so let's see how the
proof goes right so you can take eight
to be this probability measure Overstock
which would be a uniform copy of things
and I claim if you prove that this
sufficiently spread out
right if you prove that with this R this
is spread out
right so if you prove like that this is
uh
for this P that I just obviously like
you know things are working will work
out in a way but
for this piece
for this R this is spread out this is
this is the eight is spread out for this
ad
you're done because apply the spread
dilemma right so it sells you for k
equal the number of edges of H and this
R you're done like you have an existence
of a copy of it so it's
it's like this right so right so make
make the model like log of the edges and
R is p the the modified Direction
so as long as you prove that this is the
spreadness parameter of the Corpus okay
you're done by this product like this
you get this uh right so this result I I
promise to you right
okay maybe maybe it's worse maybe to
make it a little bit more clear what
does it mean to be an upper bound on the
criticality it means that the
probability of G containing a copy of
Fates is bigger than half right that's
what we're after and we prove that it's
bigger than 0.9 okay
right so we just need to prove
spreadness of
it I mean yeah it's you play this
industry but yeah right I just want to
make the claims
that's one idea we are left before the
end of the proof we want to evaluate now
this right so we want to evaluate the
probability that the
but the specific as
contains in random copyright so there's
no GMP anymore that's a nice thing about
the spread Lemma right jnp is done we
just need to prove a
structural profit on the state space if
you want okay so you need to prove we
need to prove that if you choose right
so take all the possible copies of
Trades
and you want to check what fraction of
them contains a nest okay that's what
you want but this is arbitrary agents
that's a difficult video
and we do a symmetry actually and after
it becomes very easy
randomizes okay so you have no reason
to compute this thing for a specific
copy of s if s is here or you take a
random copy of s by vertex symmetry of
the of the of the graph here it's the
same picture the same fraction of of
Fates is coverage
oh okay so if if I if I have two copies
of this locally they look the same into
what type of effects is cover them they
have no reason so I take the uniform uh
in the whole day and I take the tune
from the whole KN I take with uniform
measure all the isomorphic
okay perfect independent of AIDS and I'm
just claiming you know the same thing
it's not super deep if you want to
surprise symmetry makes vertex symmetry
makes the same pixel here and here in
terms of s and dates
actually
yeah and now what I'm saying is now
fixate also you have no reason to keep
page random I mean if you fix the nades
right so you know you just condition on
things okay right so if you now fixate
there's no reason also to make any
difference like if you fix a Nate and
see how many aces are inside it's just
it's just a double counting the people
you know
right exactly exactly it's like the same
thing the order of
I know that's good because what's a
fraction of s's inside the specific copy
of AIDS it's just this object that I
told you before the number of copies of
face inmates
divide by the number of copies of s in K
of n
so that's the formula so if you if you
raise everything to one over to the to
the edges you get like the the
spreadness that you want
so like that's exactly okay so maybe I
like so what I'm saying is we have
proven that this thing
is this thing equality right
and what I'm saying is you remember what
the tilde is foreign
right so
you can just like make a Samsung NS here
admittedly there is a two here okay but
so it's at most this equality is true
that's it so that's kind of the proof
Texas
okay uh now I would promise to you that
I want to do something with Statistics
though okay so
that's exactly again the setting so
let's you know take it really like this
is the the modified threshold I told you
like this is the the formula and this is
correct but I also promised you there is
another thing at least to me and
actually that's how historically kind of
time wise we got into the project
because we're working on inference and
we know the some connections so like
there is a way to use inference to
actually get the spread level so let me
let me okay and let me in the last 10
minutes right or so
but really okay so okay so you will get
a little bit of taste of the influence
okay okay so cool so so the speed limit
is this again you choose your favorite
choice of sub grubs
and there is actually one lie I'd not
lie one I actually you know like I make
it sound a little bit worse actually as
long as there's any probability measure
it doesn't need to be you know
supporting on the gis which is up spread
the the conclusion is correct
so I made it more digestible if you want
for the uniform measure because that's
how we applied it but actually it's true
for any measure so like again as long as
you define your favorite probability
measure supporting the gis which is
spread enough
you're done
okay
and you know just like it's super quick
literature then for the thing but it
deserves it I think like this thing is
is the key proposition that's a flower
conjunction with the improves the supply
transaction by always Lopez and
fractional can Collide by fraction Park
uh and you know how is it proven now
okay so this proposition is proven in
these two works by delicate count doing
but it's actually short proof so like
I'm not saying it's like a short group
but it requires some thought okay of how
to actually count things and make it
work
and you know also I want to say that
like clues that it's giving more made it
with high probability if you want with
the
like you should be the same bound so
there is some also work like this but
then actually people got interested okay
so like anuprao gave a proof of this
thing not with scouting but actually
with information Theory so like they
managed to find and encode the scheme
like he managed to find and code the
same and use the converse of sun on a
communication Channel noiseless actually
theorem to get the result so there is
different approach and then Terence Tau
also in his blog like offered a new
proof which uses just sound on Android
manipulations of this red level
okay so like uh it's actually quite
non-trivial like it does but like it's
true it's like sun Olympic manipulation
okay
so like what I won't tell you is that
like a new and I claim it's principle
proof the moment you you take an
inference mindset in how you look at
this but not not if you want a
combinatorial or probabilistic Minds
okay
okay cool I mean obviously it's not like
super super easy but it's principle at
least so let's see I mean but and I
would say short maybe okay so like let's
say so how does this work
okay maybe I need to yeah
I need to copy it somehow the statement
because I couldn't fit everything in one
slide
um okay so what is the setting what
we're trying to prove
who are trying to prove that the uh
Lemma
that says uh
you choose your favorite gi's sorry
sorry graphs okay when
the number of friends is at most okay
and there is a pi which is R spread
and it's supported
on the gis
and then GNP contains one of the GIS
right uh with probability
wait
okay now education will be annoyed by
the quantifiers here but yeah okay for
free at least still not okay overall
right with C is universal right and with
probability 0.9 okay
okay so this is what we've been trying
to prove and okay so everything is there
if you feel lost uh okay so what's that
all the proofs go by a duration of a
certain argument okay so like it's not
that you can do unfortunately very
direct proof so far but you need to
iterate a specific proposition a bunch
of times local times so what happens in
null proofs is that you start with that
spread measure you know you have by
assumption
and you find another spread measure a
prime
which has two very nice properties
first of all it is that spread that
helps with hydrating the proposition
and also supported exactly in the same
graphs okay so the support didn't change
in Social spread
okay but then also it has another nice
property that location goes you go to
densities one over R like constant
overrat without the low K comes from
either anything then actually okay
ideally you would like to say one
element of the support of a or a prime
is containing z
but you get something like almost this
so like what you get like almost
something looking similar but like
approximately
you get the following thing that this a
prime
the expected value of a prime minus J
which is like number of edges that Z
missed to actually like include all of
the sample of a prime okay so like I
dare you would like this to be zero
right if I prime out to something which
is the support of a prime which is a
part of a which totally including G
you're done
and what you care in your cabbage you do
every waiting if you want of a and in a
way that like a lot of edges are
included in Z in particular a small
fraction of the if you just close
sampling from a what you will get
it's a it takes a little bit of time to
digest this like it's it's a but it's an
approximate if you want version of what
you want right it tells you that like
the edges you miss by the sample okay
you first request a and then you sample
and then this gives you something that
like it's coupled with GNP obviously in
a way so that you miss something that
you can be Quantified
and in a way to be like a small fraction
of the number of another GI if you want
right and then I realized something here
there's an e here okay so this is the
edges of this and the edges of this and
I'm really sorry like in my mind this
upsets right so this is Edges analysis
okay so like if you take the expected
value of if you take a random name you
see the number of phases of a what I'm
saying is that like the number of edges
that's missed in a prime minus three are
small so somehow in this right it's not
an expectation
it's an expectation respect to the
randoms of GMP and this a prime so
there's a coupling here that you need to
be done
so like what do you want
is the number of edges
yes yes I'm really sorry for this yeah
yeah and it's this in the same she has
key or not right so this is zinc ping
but what is the expectation on the right
because just something for me this was J
Over N like from the aspect measures so
but it could be that your e of A and B
of A Try change a lot somehow okay
but there isn't somehow what we do a
prime which is not spread the big wave
Prime will start spread and then you
prove that actually a time minus the
condition of this also Express
because I'm not my comments then you
start stacking gnps on top of each other
and there is a condition make this right
so okay one is the one way to get the
locate imagine this taking to the power
of them if you're at the rate and price
at least at most K say frame is okay you
can kill this thing and you get the
non-trivial mass of the empty set which
exactly what
okay
I don't see that because when you
iterate you don't get e of a you get e
of a prime no exactly yeah yeah no you
need to change this so for you apply
this for a equal a prime minus t
that's right and then you need the yeah
and then do either
okay so in the last very few times I
want to tell you like what's the
connection with the inference so like
this blue as I told you this is what
information Theory comes in this is what
Dell kept counting comes in what we do
is we take an inference standpoint and
we Define a prime as the posterior of a
certain inference task okay and this
helps us a lot specifically what do we
do we do something that's known in plan
as planning trick and actually in the
study of random quarter satisfaction
problems
uh which is the following okay you need
to define the same Prime right so you
need to find this relating on the
support of a
so what you do is you take this uh this
example
okay you're sampling
it seems like the planet click model if
you're familiar with this like it's okay
with something like hey something done
we will couple everything a prime DNA
and then with something D independently
okay
and then we okay so and then we need to
find a prime okay so then we see this as
the observation graph
and we take a Prime from the posterior
of a given y so we try to find a if you
want given y Okay this may sound very
weird but like I will explain why we do
this okay but is there what we Define
the posterior a prime is the posterior
so the posterior if you want is your
best guess of where a stands given way
that's why the posterior is okay so why
why do we do this here first of all okay
this relates to the planet
by Vegas rule a prime and a have the
same marginals
okay which is very important here
because the first property is done this
is our spread measure
and the support is the same like it's
the same distribution marginally okay so
this this is why the posterior is very
important here
and then okay so and then okay so we
need to prove this weird thing right so
we need to prove that like the a Prime C
has very fewer edges much fewer
resistant name
but what is really a prime minus G okay
so a prime minus Z what it is a prime
the the
a prime what does it do right it looks
at what Y is and tries to find a
right so a is an element of the support
of a so what it does it tries to find
the other elements in the support of a
now that are including in the Y and just
puts appropriate Mass into it that's it
breaks a guess of what they want that's
what posterior is doing so a Prem is
inside y
so what is a prime minus Z right it's
all included here
veggies that it misses because like it
outputs something in the way so you're
really asking here this thing is what
you're asking if you want you're an
upper bound like it's suffice to show
that the edges in the posterior
intersection the prior is more
okay and this in inference
right it's it's an MSC so like so what
is that what is my biggest rule we know
that the posterior sampling is the
optimal estimator in minimizing the
square data
so like exactly this idea in a different
Channel if you want to to take
intersection of posterior and prior and
have a small Mass that's exactly what it
means that inference is impossible in
the Square direct sense
okay so hopefully you're familiar with
it but I'm saying otherwise I'm really
sorry if if you're not what is this
posterior think we are think I'm saying
this is called me some more identity
physics but I mean it's a yeah yeah okay
Chris got me okay but yeah I'm happy to
explain more but yeah I guess I need to
conclude so it's uh but happy to talk
more about this and actually you know
last last comment here is that MMS is
now being large
is is something right so this is very
large so like mmsc reconstructing name
from is very large because that's the
next platform so the previous zero
estimator so what I'm saying is I'm
gonna this is a property of essentially
something not happening like you know as
we call nothing in the in the in the
inference world it's like oh Lord
nothing another phase transition and
what this is if you just about what is
good here after you've done this
interpretation this is vanilla analyzing
the posterior distribution that anybody
can do if you tell us is the formula of
the posterior just expand things out so
there is no more magic after this so
it's like and that's the nice thing and
actually maybe interestingly from an
observation point of view like if you
just do you know somebody could try to
prove this thing by second moment right
it's a GNP property of including one GI
this ends up being like a sort of second
moment method that I otherwise I could
then at least and I don't think I know
Michael laborator shouldn't make sense
of the second moment method it's not
conditional or anything or negative it's
a different type which right it it
actually implies all these nice
implications by posterior and stuff but
it doesn't mean anything by itself in
probability so that's a nice coupling I
think
uh something then as I told you this
relates actually with the notion of all
or not phenomenon but that's probably
for another okay and yeah this is the
talk uh this is the work and uh you know
there are a bunch of open questions and
that I will Super quickly don't say okay
so like this is here like and we
characterize what thresholds and can we
study more there's a spreadness and the
connection and thank you very much sorry
for taking it
thank you very much
thank you for this very exciting talk
are there any further questions because
we already have quite a few
uh yeah sure Chris by all means
so my first question is can you
generalize this to conicalize nth
conjecture but uh you're right yeah
right yeah this is this is nice at least
at least historically right I mean yeah
they conjecture something we have a an
exact upper log though like
understanding of it whatever we have
tried does this possession subgroups we
get the same prediction so there is
evidence that it's the same actually let
some help yeah but I don't know I don't
know this gives room for proving or
refuting
so that that symmetry argument applies
and I think you're in where you're
referring you're alluding to this here
it applies for instance in if I take any
Edge transitive graph like say a Kaylee
graph of a group or a shire graph and
then I do percolation on that it would
apply it right either as well I'm uh you
know I'm afraid to claim something I
don't know what details but I would
think so right and so I just I I loved
the conclusion of the talk so I just
wanna see if I have the right intuition
okay so you know second moment methods
are badly off when there are a lot of
intersections between uh typical pairs
your example of the K4 plus an antenna
the point is that most pairs would share
the same K4 and just a little same
antennas same thing with hamiltonian
paths and so on and right but yeah and
so did that that re-waiting argument
should I think of that as
inventing a new random variable so that
I'm now doing a weighted second moment
method
um you mentioned truncation so I think
it's it's not so it's not quite the
waiting thing it's actually funny yeah
so like like what happens is that
so what happens is the volume no like if
you just apply your weight it's second
moment method which is what the I think
is more natural for this prior is that
it's a it doesn't work for example for
Passive matching but what happens is
that because the mmsc like what you are
good trying to do for the MSC you get
kind of as you expand the second moment
you get all the possible overlaps Right
so it suffices to consider all the high
overlaps and that's what them and
surprising as a truncation which I
cannot make sense by itself but actually
exactly corresponds what the mmsc is
asking so like so that's what I'm saying
there is some there is my competition I
think I haven't seen but maybe somebody
will have since I'm not playing you know
or we haven't seen and I think but like
you know but yeah but the by doing the
posterior thing but uh yeah I mean there
are also very nice other groups of this
what you almost said at the end and
maybe you did say is that when GNP
crosses the point where it's information
theoretically distinguishable whether
you planted a copy of a in it or not in
particular we know that there probably
is a copy of a approximately right
exactly yeah there is a small line
between exact and approximate recovery
here okay but you're right conceptually
you're completely right exactly if you
this is using the information Authority
threshold to get information about the
null if you want of the blending model
something by the way that like people
have done like in the past in the
context of like condensation first
edition or something like this but but
uh but like yeah exactly so this is what
we do but there is a small delicate I
would say detail of like approximate
here we only want to say it's hard to
get the full thing or or getting the
Almost Perfect Production okay but there
is a small right but yeah and so should
I think of the log K shy I think of that
log Factor as sort of the gap between a
copy of a problem exists versus there
are so many copies of a that you can't
even tell whether I planted one
ah no okay interesting no no no because
the information theoretic threshold
route obviously been upper bound and I
but I don't know like for planted Clique
it's not far off and I anyway right so I
think the way I think the logarithm is
similar but not exactly this is more
like at this level of densities without
the logarithm you can get an approximate
perfect matching or something like this
because right then there's something in
the null now in the planet what it means
is we can recover the planted margin
approximately but like uh right I think
what the log buys you at least in this
proof though and unsure about you know
all the cases is that you know it takes
you to complete kind of the sub graph
sequentially but uh but yeah I mean I
yeah I mean about the uh the gap between
what like I don't have an understanding
in exactly in the last thing maybe in
the interest of time
yes again
[Applause]
foreign